you're on to me i hate them babies just
don't tell my wife and my one-year-old
daughter okay that's gonna be an awkward
conversation what are you like eight
years old yeah i'm pro-choice i'm
pro-reproductive freedom that doesn't
mean i [ __ ] hate babies what is wrong
with you you guys have such a black and
white way of thinking about the world
you know there are multiple nuanced
reasons to believe in things you can be
anti-war and still support the troops
you can be anti-capitalist and still
love freedom it's not about hating
babies it's about health
and healthcare decisions and who has the
right to make those decisions first of
all the vast majority of abortions don't
even require an abortive surgery they're
done through an abortion pill but of the
abortions that do make it to the surgery
stage
the vast vast majority are done within
the first trimester usually within 12
weeks when the baby's just a clump of
cells it's not even a baby you guys are
seriously under the delusion that people
make it to like eight months nine months
in their pregnancy and then go oh you
know what i don't want to [ __ ] kill
it that literally never [ __ ] happens
if somebody's having an abortion that
late it's because of a medical necessity
they're not waiting nine months and then
deciding to use abortion as birth
control at nine months you have the room
decorated you have the name picked out
you're bringing home toys from your
friends and dr hand me down clothes
that's not when you decide to have an
abortion at that period you're counting
the minutes from the time the baby
stopped kicking
because you're so [ __ ] afraid that if
it doesn't kick it's dead are you a
father are you a parent do you know how
this thing works no do you know how the
psyche of a parent works nobody kills
their own [ __ ] children because it's
because it gets them off because it's a
hobby my wife had a procedure at eight
weeks to get rid of an ectopic pregnancy
it's called a dnc essentially they go in
and they scrape out the baby it's an
abortive procedure it's the same
procedure they use an abortion the baby
was already dead because it was an
ectopic pregnancy well technically it
was still alive but it was more of like
a parasite and it would have killed my
wife if we had left it in but the
insurance company coded it as an
abortion because it's a typical abortion
procedure what's to say in some of these
states where they're outlawing they have
blanket outlaws and he's making a really
good point here because a dnc which you
know he's not a woman i'm not a woman we
would never have a dnc but a dnc is a is
a very uh
common procedure in that it saves the
woman's life so what happens what
happens in texas now if a woman receives
a dnc or she has to cross a state line
and is it does someone get a bounty on
her or how many people get bounties
that's what i want to know too let's say
this woman lives in a really crowded
neighborhood and about 20 of her
neighbors find out that she has had a
dnc to save her life to all 20 people
get to sue her because they're offended
think about that do all 20 of them i
mean really
i mean honestly
why not why why wouldn't 20 people or is
it only one bounty is it only one bounty
or anyone who wants a bounty which is it
which is it texas which is it
men who don't have uteruses that are
making laws for people who do have
uteruses called women
which is it
let's listen to the rest of the video
because of a board of procedures that my
wife would not have been able to get
that procedure to rid herself of that
ectopic pregnancy in which case she
would have [ __ ] died and my
one-year-old living breathing daughter
would never have made it to this world
it's literally none of your [ __ ]
business why women choose to have an
abortion like none period across the
board it's not up to you it's their
[ __ ] body they can do whatever the
[ __ ] they want but it's only use small
government types that think it's the
government's responsibility to come and
tell a woman what she can do with her
own [ __ ] reproductive organs kind of
dystopian [ __ ] is that if you really
were that concerned about stopping
unwanted pregnancies and therefore
stopping abortions you'd mandate
vasectomy
because men are capable of getting a
woman pregnant 365 days a year a woman
can only get pregnant once every nine
months
and i've seen a lot of people post this
that maybe maybe we should put
a bounty
on on men i mean
you know you could make the argument
that men actually get women pregnant so
maybe we should put the bounty on men
not women
maybe if you put the bounty on men
maybe that would change a whole hell of
a lot of minds about a law and bounties
i mean you know
if you if
if for some reason some reason you
decide to you know spank the old monk
maybe and someone finds out about it
maybe there should be a ten thousand
dollar bounty i mean you wasted all
all that seed
right and
[ __ ] break
you don't want to take it that far
increase access to birth control and
comprehensive sex education baffles me
that you guys are anti-abortion and
anti-birth control it was never about
stopping abortion it's about controlling
women
you're on to me i hate them baby